bernard mono bonjour merci de répondre à
nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
accord pour 1800 milliards d'euros fonds
de relance et les budgets confondus
une enveloppe qui met fin aux
divergences ou qui les masques plutôt
n'aurait coûté s'éteint c'est une
illusion ce plan de relance européen est
une illusion il faut savoir que les
états et en particulier la france ont
tout à fait les moyens financiers de
pouvoir s'autofinancer via notre banque
centrale la banque de france voire
accessoirement la banque centrale
européenne et que le passage aux 40
milliards oui enfin on donne 100 billard
et et puis on reçoit 40 donc le calcul
est vite fait c'est en fait le problème
est politique c'est à dire que nous
n'avons pas besoin politiquement et
techniquement de financement de l'union
européenne
d'autant que c'est l'argent de la france
qui passe par bruxelles nous pouvons
avoir un financement par une politique
monétaire et de toute manière quand on
voit la mise en oeuvre
pénible de ce plan de relance européen
on peut tout à fait dire que c'est
inutile c'est trop tard et c'est très
complexe d'autant qu'il va falloir en
plus dans leur processus de plan
européen
passé par la ratification des états des
états membres donc si vous la tout ça va
arriver trop tard
si toutefois ça arrive ça va être très
compliqué et moi je pense qu'il ya
d'autres solutions c'est à dire passer
par les états membres même si on nous
fait miroiter 1800 milliards mais c'est
au niveau des 27 pays donc fait le
calcul fait la division ça va être
dérisoire au niveau de la france nous
avons un besoin pour 2020 et 2021
d'environ 350 milliards d'euros
donc on est loin du compte avec les 40
milliards qui va être une aumône pour la
france sur le plan diplomatique
autre accord avec des sanctions contre
contre la turquie union de façade
ou pragmatisme de circonstance face à
une menace commune
c'est là ça démontre cette fois ci que
une robe des coopérations peut
fonctionner quand on est à peu près tous
d'accord et que dans l'eau culan en
l'occurrence avec la turquie il ya une
vraie menace diplomatique politique
voire militaire et que effectivement là
il fallait s'entendent contre un pays
qui n'a rien à faire du tout dans
l'union européenne malgré les ouvertures
de processus d'intégrer la turquie dans
l'union européenne depuis depuis vingt
ans déjà
donc si vous voulez oui là c'est plutôt
positif dans une logique de coopération
de l'ensemble des états membres de
l'europe
autre sujet à l'environnement les 27 à
viennent d'annoncer un accord pour
réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'au moins 55% d'ici 2030
réalisable selon vous va écouter les
réalisable au niveau des états sachant
que la france est un des pays les moins
que l'eau au monde compte tenu de son
système de centrales nucléaires et que
la politique le tir est écologique et
verte de l'union européenne à amène à
fermer des centrales nucléaires et
ouvrir les centrales thermiques qui sont
extrêmement polluantes comme on le voit
en allemagne et bientôt en france donc
c'est contre-productif
c'est les solutions de l'union
européenne sont mauvaises dans le cadre
de l'écologie et il ya aussi d'autres
solutions bien plus performante
ce que je regrette lors de ce sommet
européen c'est qu'on n'est pas du tout
abordé le sujet des grandes migrations
mondial signé dans le cadre du pacte de
marrakech notamment par la france en
décembre 2018
normalement ça devrait aller dans l'est
l'ordre du jour du sommet européen pour
avoir un premier bilan deux ans après
sur la question du pacte de marrakech
les grandes migrations mondial et je
suis très étonné que ces sujets la
politique majeur ne soit pas du tout
abordé lors d'un sommet européen comme
celui ci en revanche est un autre sujet
inquiets
et très abordé en tous les cas d'ici
dimanche soir on attendait des réponses
et le brésil de fortes possibilités que
les négociations échouent selon les mots
cette nuit de boris johnson la banque
d'angleterre ce matin par l 2 bis de
perturbation des services financiers qui
pourraient survenir ça veut dire que le
new deal est inéluctable ou est-ce que
c'est simplement un coup de bluff de la
part de boris johnson selon vous noro je
crois que ça c'est de la politique
politicienne de court terme ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il y ait dit le no
deal
elle n'a aucune espèce d'importance
l'union de la le royaume uni le 31
décembre va sortir de dumas du marché
unique et de l'union douanière ça c'est
un fait
le seul point positif pour la france
parce que c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
que effectivement l'union cas le royaume
uni fait la démonstration qu'on peut
rétablir les frontières nationales pour
pouvoir réguler la circulation des
marchandises des biens de la finance
avec les capitaux et puis également les
personnes donc ça c'est plutôt très
positif de réguler les frontières
nationales et c'est le seul point
positif du bric site pour la france même
si la banque d'angleterre prévoit donc
des perturbations des services
financiers ce matin merci bernard mono
d'avoir répondu à nos questions